[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay kawhi
it's the conference semifinals you could
try to roll a 20 to hit an off-balance
buzz beat over envy
no way that's impossible roll it one to
15 and we can
regroup in over time don't listen to
gasol
take the play off for load management
guys
i got this it's all part of the game
[Music]
yeah victory we won and we is crying
and we won hey guys can i play no
pal he refuses to retire
charge charge follow you
hey dwight is kawhi home no my boy never
came home last night and i think he's
trying to send me a message through the
canada daylights
[Music]
what is he trying to tell us i can't
crack the code
don't worry drake we'll find him you
should check the sports science lab on
the outskirts of town i'd go myself
but i was banned for giving nick nurse a
shoulder rub
are we going to get in easy the lab is
defended by the washington wizards
if you get past bradley bill there's
zero help three on one
three on one little help hey wait
stop
thank god everything in this town is a
short bike ride apart
now let's fan out and find kawaii you
won't find him here
it's too late dr rivers
i believe raptor's red thanks van bleet
you can call me 23.
kawhi went through that portal the
upside down
well technically the j bill is
tremendous upside down
deal smeal the upside down is even worse
than i imagined
i think this is just downtown los
angeles there's kawaii
and danny green we don't care about him
kawhi
[Music]
the dimmer georgian but seriously kawhi
can't go back i blew up my old team to
play with him
he's right sorry guys i'm staying here
what we want to campaign together don't
you realize how rare that is in toronto
and
what's so special about this guy well
when healthy he's an excellent two-way
denver georgian
vaquoi we had a historic run come on
don't you want to defend our title no
it's 70 degrees and sunny here
i'm tired of children's games and most
of all i just don't want to play with
you guys anymore
fine we don't need you anyway we're
still a respectable 2c
all right pascal it's game seven of the
conference semifinals
you need to roll a 15 or a 10 to send it
into overtime
outcome unclear but pascal kicked daniel
ties in the face
no i am the real chris paul you want the
real deal especially when it comes to
home and auto insurance
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
you